[Music]
on this tuesday night from edmonton the
pope's faithful pack a football stadium
holy mass delivered to tens of thousands
that's once in a lifetime and the
critical step forward on the journey to
truth and reconciliation the one sort of
golden discovery that i made was
syntax of a different sort it is a kind
of
revenge evaluates new bylaw for churches
after the revealing of unmarked graves
one athlete's childhood dream turns into
a nightmare i became suicidal the
multiplying calls to overhaul hockey's
toxic culture and a top officer grilled
new revelations at the nova scotia
massacre inquiry
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from edmonton mithu
garcia
[Music]
we are in fort edmonton tonight at the
indigenous people's experience an
immersive cultural exhibition that's
seen a delegation of catholic bishops as
well as prime minister justin trudeau
visit over the past few days
good evening and thanks for joining us
all eyes today were focused minutes from
here as pope francis hosted the largest
event of his canadian tour
in the name of the father
of the phone
and of the holy spirit
peace be with you
the pope welcomed more than 50 000
people to edmonton's commonwealth
stadium for a public open-air mass it
was less than expected but it was still
a crowd big enough to nearly fill
canada's largest stadium
today's mass garnered global attention
with parishioners traveling from around
the world to see the pope speak but it's
in the community of lac saint anne
northwest of edmonton where many
indigenous people saw the head of the
catholic church participate in a
pilgrimage at the site believed to have
healing powers that's where we find our
heather ux west tonight heather tell us
what's happening
me too the the pope is still speaking to
the crowd of about 2 000 people that
have gathered here he is leading a
prayer service as we speak uh telling
the crowd that you know their presence
here shows their their resilience um
and and and that their their ability to
heal so as the crowd here continues to
to listen to his words i know that many
are hoping to hear words of apology from
the pope
as they heard yesterday
the pope is spending about an hour in
total here in laxain and a deeply
spiritual place for indigenous people
and indigenous catholics and catholics
uh uh that are non-indigenous as well uh
people have been making a pilgrimage to
this community to a lake that the alexis
dakota people call
god's lake ever since and dakota chief
many many generations ago followed a
vision and brought his people up to
settle around these waters the waters as
you mentioned are believed to have
healing powers and after he arrived the
pope in a wheelchair made his way down
the newly paved pathway that was paved
just for his visit
down to the water where he blessed a
small amount of the water
thousands of people as i said gathered
to see the pope here just as thousands
gathered to see him earlier today at
commonwealth stadium in edmonton
at edmonton's commonwealth stadium pope
francis arrives to cheers
some in the crowd waiting since sunrise
to get in all anxious to get a glimpse
of the holy father hoping to take a
picture or have their young children
blessed with a kiss it's like a once in
a lifetime opportunity i'm catholic been
catholic my whole life and
it's you know something that's very
important to me i'm thrilled
i feel blessed
that i was able to be this close to him
and he acknowledged me by waving but the
open air mass was planned with
reconciliation in mind
the liturgy designed by father christina
bouvette who is crete metis my paternal
grandmother spent 12 years of her life
her entire education in the indian
residential school system brothers and
sisters
let us acknowledge our sins pope francis
appearing solomon sincere praying for
first nations inuit and metis people a
future in which the history of violence
and marginalization
suffered by our indigenous brothers and
sisters
is never repeated a powerful message
with many residential school survivors
and their families in the crowd
while others gathered west of the city
in the community of setan
roya cross attended the beau val
residential school in northern
saskatchewan for eight years as a young
boy
he says he's been waiting decades to
hear the words of apology in person from
the pope i would say
ever since
we went to school ever since then i
guess you could say i wanted to have my
parents with me when i went to school i
never had that
if i had problems i would have went to
my parents and talked to them but i
couldn't that privilege was taken away
from me like so many others necrosh is
hoping to heal and hoping an encounter
with pope francis will help him find
forgiveness and freedom so he may
finally move on
the pope is still speaking with the
crowd that has gathered here this is of
course his last stop uh in his uh in the
edmonton leg of his canadian tour
tomorrow
he he will leave
edmonton and continue on to his two
other stops in iqaluit and quebec city
back to you
and we will have extensive coverage of
both heather urex west in lac saint and
alberta thanks heather
the release of residential school
records has been a persistent yet
unsuccessful request from indigenous
communities in the lead-up to this trip
tonight though news of a major
revelation from the first canadian
researcher ever to access a trove of
records in rome hundreds of original
images of children in residential
schools across canada that few have ever
seen and while more is still needed many
believe this unprecedented access is a
big step forward in the pursuit for
truth and justice
raymond frogner has made what he calls a
golden discovery one that could make it
much easier to identify children who
died in canada's residential schools
these are original photographs that i
don't think communities have ever seen i
saw photographs from some of the some of
the more prominent schools that have
been in news lately the cowassess
the kamloops pinellakit
the six nations of the grand river
frogner found the images earlier this
month when he was granted exclusive
access to the oblate general archives in
rome a vast collection of records
separate from the vatican archives
containing everything from personal
files of priests and residential school
staff to individual pitchers
1 000 photographs black and white with
handwritten descriptions on the back and
these photos were sent by various
priests from different schools and
locations in canada back to rome he also
took with him a list of priests charged
with crimes committed against children
in residential schools i was kept under
watch as i was going through the
archival records but i was able to
request any files
and they would retrieve for me the next
step is to digitize the photographs and
records so copies exist in canada and
are available to families
this is a phenomenal
step forward the national center for
truth and reconciliation is also
examining records of other institutions
like missions and industrial schools day
school survivors like incoming
university of ottawa chancellor
claudette commanda say exposing the
truth can bring closure to communities
the discovery of these documents that
have never been seen before
except by the vatican well that is one
step
one big major step
and that is very critical
in bringing healing and justice and
disclosure to the survivors and their
families as for some of the records in
canada calgary bishop william mcgrattan
told global news in may they'll be
digitized and accessible within three
years if their loved ones did attend a
residential school and were buried in a
cemetery that was adjacent to a parish
or a mission we would have those
sacramental records and we're trying to
make those available but moscow cheese
resident lucy johnson says it's
important to acknowledge how long it's
taken to get here they should have been
released 20 years ago why keep them
hidden in rome for decades quite
honestly i think if it was not for the
discovery of the unmarked gravesites
from 2021
i don't think i would have made that
being able to make that trip to rome and
quite frankly i don't think we'd have
seen the apology from the pope he says a
total of nearly 4 million documents and
7 thousand witness statements have been
archived so far and communities looking
to access them can make their request
directly through the national center for
truth and reconciliation
later in the newscast rethinking the
role of the church a closer look at a
polarizing tax on churches in canada's
northernmost city
and a reminder that if you or someone
you know who is a residential school
survivor are looking for help you can
call the residential school survivors
and family crisis line anytime the
number is 1-800-721-0066
turning now to other news canada's
sports minister spoke to a house of
commons committee today about the
ongoing investigation into hockey canada
and its handling of sexual assault
allegations as shalima maharaja reports
issues of not addressing abuse have been
plaguing hockey culture for decades
i did see a lot of a lot of things that
now as a 35 year old father i look at
and i'm like wow that that really was
not right brady livold was 16 years old
when he left home to play in the western
hockey league chasing an nhl dream that
would become a nightmare back in those
days hazing and bullying was was really
prevalent and i was one of the guys on
the team that got got it really bad and
it got to the point where i became
suicidal and i wasn't running to my
coaches or anybody to tell them because
and that was just going to make it worse
right
insight into problematic parts of
established hockey culture in this
country now under increasing scrutiny
you're made to feel
almost like you are more special than
other people and it's hard to navigate
that as a young man at 16 17 18 you have
all these people who are telling you how
great you are and how much they love you
it's hard to keep that ego in check
hockey canada is under fire after
revelations it used a special fund to
settle sexual assault claims and two
criminal investigations involving men's
junior teams are now reopened officials
will testify before a parliamentary
committee wednesday so you didn't
consider it a significant risk that an
organization
was under under a cloud of sexual
assault allegations you didn't consider
that was a sufficient risk to flag this
at each time these
funding decisions were being made
at the time we were waiting for the
results of the investigation the people
that were present in the past decade and
in the past years and in the events of
2018 and how they manage the whole
situations are they really the right
leaders to implement the change
that hockey culture needs former nhler
sheldon kennedy a victim of sexual abuse
in youth hockey issued a statement
calling for the resignation of hockey
canada's ceo scott smith the
organization's leadership team and its
board of directors tuesday saying the
same people with a new plan expecting
different results is the definition of
insanity nitu
thanks shalima
fresh revelation spawning questions at
the nova scotia massacre inquiry coming
up what a top rcmp officer said on the
stand
we are at the indigenous people's
experience on the banks of the north
saskatchewan river on treaty six
territory this land is a traditional
gathering place for diverse indigenous
peoples including the cree dene
anishnabe nakota blackfoot and metis
people we'll be right back
british columbians are sweltering under
another dangerous heat wave blanketing
most of the province with warnings from
environment canada the metro vancouver
area faces highs around 35 degrees while
parts of bc's interior including the
city of kamloops and the village of
litton are expected to endure
temperatures up to 40 degrees throughout
the week the scorching conditions may
not start cooling down until this
weekend at the earliest
the rcmp officer in charge of the
investigation into nova scotia's worst
mass shooting that left 22 people dead
revealed why he was concerned about
political interference surrounding the
probe yesterday rcmp commissioner brenda
lucky denied any meddling in the case
but today chief superintendent darren
campbell said he stands by his notes
taken during a conference call with
lucky two years ago ross lord reports
i'm truly sorry that we failed you
i promise that we'll do better
rcmp superintendent darren campbell
broke down addressing the families of
victims before the mass casualty
commission's public inquiry a rare
moment of raw emotion recalling a day
that changed countless families forever
earlier campbell spoke of why he didn't
want his national boss brenda lucky
pressuring him to reveal details about
the killer's weapons
i was very concerned that if
if it was political if it was
politically motivated
how the families would perceive that
that bothered me commissioner lucky and
federal cabinet minister bill blair both
deny allegations of political
interference but campbell's testimony
featured other revelations some leading
a lawyer for victims families to wonder
how many recommendations from previous
tragedies involving rcmp members have
been implemented are you able to say
chief superintendent campbell if that
tac threat assessment coordinator was in
place in nova scotia i'm not in a
position to say that campbell also
admits to being part of the decision to
charge the killer's long time partner
lisa banfield with supplying him with
ammunition police admit banfield had no
idea he would go on a murder spree and
evidence showed she was a long-time
abuse victim living in fear and did the
optics include that it might be
perceived
as an attempt to divert
attention from the responsibility of the
rcmp for
what had happened on the
the night of the murders no
that that actually never crossed my mind
banfield's charges were eventually moved
from the courts to restorative justice
she's been discharged with no criminal
record
ross lord global news
the campaign to free brittany griner
ahead the legal battle to prove russia
wrongfully detained the american
basketball star
global national is back from edmonton
after this
[Music]
welcome back to edmonton now to
washington where former u.s president
donald trump returned for the first time
since leaving office
we have become a beggar nation groveling
to other countries for energy
millions of illegal aliens are
stampeding across our wide open borders
pouring into our country it's an
invasion
democrat-run cities are setting all time
trump is being advised to speak more
about his vision for the future and less
about the 2020 election that he claims
was stolen by joe biden
today trump made his case for a possible
second term ahead of the november
midterm election saying america is
facing an energy crunch fueled by
democrat policies
european union member states agreed on a
plan to reduce natural gas consumption
as russia cut supply and the war in
ukraine shows no end in sight the bloc
agreed to temporarily lower demand for
natural gas by 15 percent but says the
move may become mandatory if russia
turns off the taps completely and
storage levels drop dramatically the
deal was reached a day after russian
energy giant gazprom announced it was
cutting daily gas deliveries to germany
in half from 40 percent down to 20
percent
american basketball star brittany griner
appeared in a russian court today her
fifth hearing after being arrested in
february over cannabis oil found in her
luggage her defense team focused on
testimony from a narcology expert saying
that while illegal in russia cannabis is
used medicinally in other countries u.s
officials and prominent athletes have
argued she's been wrongfully detained
griner faces up to 10 years in prison if
convicted
the price of penance next why caluits
churches will soon pay a very real cost
for the atrocities of the past
we're back in a moment from edmonton
some enthralling performances earlier
today from outside the indigenous
peoples experience exhibit in fort
edmonton park that's where we've been
broadcasting to you as we cover the
second full day of pope francis's trip
in canada
to seek forgiveness from indigenous
communities
the final stop of the pope's canadian
tour will be ocalaweed on friday where
he'll briefly meet with nunavut's
residential school survivors following
the revealing of unmarked graves at
former school sites the city of iqaluit
unanimously passed a bylaw to require
churches to pay taxes as jeff semple
reports from ocala wheat some are now
rethinking the church's role
sunday morning mass in a calorie in the
name of the father and of the son and of
the holy spirit
in the remote northern cities only
catholic church parishioners are
preparing for a special visitor i told
my mom mom the pope is coming to a
coward do you want to come to italy oh
my god that's my dream to go see the
pool but yes i will come on friday pope
francis will make a brief stop in
nunavut's capital
[Music]
and these catholics will form part of
his official welcoming party it feels
great feels great at a ceremony rhoda
umala will recite the lord's prayer in
inuktatuk give me a preview of that
first one line or two
first met the pope back in march part of
the delegation of indigenous leaders
invited to the vatican she delivered a
gift the seal skin pouch and a message i
told him to apologize from the from the
heart
it's long time coming
and and
and he needs to do that the pope is
expected to apologize in person to
nunavut's residential school survivors
around sixty percent of acalaweed's
population is indigenous and many were
forced to attend catholic run schools
where abuse was rampant peter archnick
was 11 when he was assaulted by a nun
for not speaking english residential
school was a horrible
living it's a horror story about
how we were taken away forcibly from our
parents the pope's apology is largely
symbolic of course but local churches
here in iqaluit may soon be forced to
pay a very real price as a result of a
bylaw passed here in april starting next
year churches will no longer be
automatically exempt from property taxes
the bylaw passed unanimously in the wake
of the discovery of unmarked graves
churches along with other community
groups must now apply for tax relief the
funding is capped with strict conditions
it is unfair
it is a kind of
revenge or a kind of game the local
catholic priest says the tax may limit
their ability to offer services from
weddings and funerals to hospital and
prison visits for free for some churches
even they can bankrupt with that tax
everyone is lacking in resources the
local mp defends the bylaw noting the
city is struggling to pay for basic
services it's not fair
to the rest of the municipality to have
to carry the burden of
a faith-based group that
itself
is part of the history of colonialism
the new tax has proved polarizing here
the per capita impact of residential
schools was highest in the north but
despite their traumatic history with the
church three-quarters of a calories
population still identifies as christian
most are anglican in the early days our
parents were very much
going to church and following
you know the
teachings of the bible abraham terelick
is a residential school survivor a
former radio host and co-founder of the
aboriginal people's television network
he believes the sun is setting on the
church's prominence they've kind of
lost the control they used to have the
young people today they don't go to
church they don't read the bible they're
not really religious in any way anymore
i think it was kind of forced on us
at that stage and
it was all part of converting us the
discovery of unmarked graves and a papal
apology are prompting a rethink over the
traditional role and rights of the
church in canada including in its
northernmost city
jeff semple global news iqaluit
and jeff will bring you global national
from quebec city tomorrow that's it for
us tonight i'm nitu garcia we'll leave
you more scenes from today's service at
commonwealth stadium thanks for watching
good night
jesus
[Music]
you